[Music]
screen huggy show with how Rodney so
according all the TV commercials the
holiday season's upon us happy Honda
days there's like a thousand and one
Christmas movies and there's only one
Hanukkah movie and it's by the guy who
made Jack and Jill we're going to change
that warning it's about to get Jew
tastic up in this your costumes
wait it's not a costume
I'm a Jewish elf from the Jewish North
Pole aka Florida are you in Santa's list
no but my grandma she was on Schindler's
List
Jew line cinema presents the story of
one Jewish elf who's coming home for
Hanukkah hey Mista do you know my daddy
he's a Jew who works in Hollywood kid
you just subscribe literally everyone
here now he'll discover a whole new
world
this Chanukah season well it is only a
few more months until Elijah comes to
town Elijah oh my god annoy I know him I
know him he'll learn a lesson about
family dad and about himself Shalom are
you a Jewish American princess
because you're making my matzo balls
Fitz
[Music]
look I am what I wanted was your mensch
and I got was a fish mark get ready to
find the holiday spirit Draya Draya
Draya with enough fun this sandwich is
great what's in it again chicken
barbecue sauce and bacon bacon for eight
days and eight nights Mazel Tov
Jewish el and don't forget we control
the banks and the media this movie could
be huge we just need the money to make
it the money call to action to all Jews
go to Twitter let's get this trending
typing at screen junkies hashtag Jew L
was this episode so anti-semitic that I
should turn in my Juke card or do we not
go far enough and should I have made my
oven joke or should we have done one of
our other ideas instead How the Grinch
Stole Hanukkah Hebrew Nationals Jewish
staycation synagogue alone dyke allah
it's a wonderful circumcision or jewish
gremlins you guys see the new Man of
Steel poster looks like he's getting
arrested what for
drunken flying Oh hop acting bizarro in
public me know am Superman bad no yes or
using his x-ray vision to check out some
boobies host your funniest reason in the
comments below and we'll send the best
one one of these babies and I'm not
talking about my nipples I'm talking
about this t-shirt I'm al Rudnick my
bike guys has always been a dream of
mine to play fantasy football actual
football with fantastical characters to
help me play fantasy football the way it
was meant to be played from FX is the
league Paul Scheer Paul how are you
great to see you thank you so much for
having me at the inaugural fantasy
fantasy football event